Shelby what do we know about this this
morning and what are companies doing to
contain this outbreak yeah well buddy
this is basically the pr nightmare just
keeps on going we find out this morning
just hours after President Obama spoke
to calm the Nation about ebola we find
out a Dallas healthcare worker is on a
Carnival Cruise ship in the Caribbean
now Carnival released a statement saying
this person is involuntary isolation the
person is not showing symptoms of Ebola
it's more of a PR scare right now than a
health than a health scare but it's
certainly raising elevating concerns
about traveling and it's coming after
news that Amber Vinson the second Dallas
nurse to get Ebola may have been sick
and traveling sick much earlier than we
thought so so she would have been
infectious then she could have been and
therefore as a precaution Frontier
Airlines is notifying hundreds of
passengers that flew on her plane after
she traveled to Cleveland
and the CDC says these passengers they
shouldn't be traveling but can they do
anything about it yeah that's the big
question so I've been speaking to law
professors they say that the state the
State Health officials usually take the
lead on things like quarantines and
travel restrictions the CDC does have
the power to issue a do not board list
there was a lot of talk about that this
week that would prevent some of these
health care workers from traveling while
they're being monitored for symptoms but
it may not prevent them from getting on
cruise ships so you know enforcing these
kind of things is very difficult and
this this person on the cruise ship left
from Galveston so they never even got on
an airplane it's really difficult to
Monitor and track them and it's also a
big restraint on civil liberties this is
a group of about 50 people yes and these
law professors said it would be
unprecedented for the government to
issue a do not board list or restrict
them from traveling and speaking about
travel need a fan who is that nurse
who's recovering yes she was transferred
to a hospital in Maryland overnight and
there's video of that online is that
right yes before she traveled to
Maryland her doctor is in Texas actually
did a little inner view with her in her
hospital room she looks great it was
very emotional there were a few tears
shed but uh it was it was great to see
on Twitter after she was leaving the
hospital there were tons of nurses out
supporting her as she was pulling away
and uh she received a lot of support on
social media as well well can you
imagine the Panic if in fact she took a
turn for the worse